[Music]
foreign
being a deep sea diver would come in
handy I thought it would probably be
jumping into a lake to save someone's
life turns out it's just me talking on
YouTube again welcome back to the true
Geordie YouTube channel so like a diver
talking about submarine stuff is like a
footballer talking about rugby these
poor people are [__] I'm not laughing
it's a very I am laughing a little bit
it's a very sad thing that's going on
here but also not surprising the more I
learn about this the more I'm like how
the hell did this even happen because my
experience of working offshore it was
incredibly safety focused to uh
annoyance you know what I mean you're
like bloody Helly people would go mad
about safety offshore but the more you
look into it the more you realize they
were really playing by the rules yeah
guilty get a new rule book he said this
is just a classic example lob we don't
need a pack of plan we'll be fine don't
worry about it man bro safety Steve come
on you used to be cool the geez behind
this is mental and everyone who paid him
money is just stupid so the truth of the
matter is these poor people are
unsavable you're highly unlikely to find
them and if you find them there's no
Oxygen left even if they were somehow
surviving barely by the time you got
them to the surface by the time it took
you however long to unbolt this [__]
door that's bolted on and the 18 bolts
or whatever you're going to take however
long to get that off there's just no way
and look I'll be surprised if they find
it I think because there's so much
publicity around it they'll probably
Fork the money out and someone will want
to find them and return them to their
loved ones because the people inside
this thing are so rich they they're
married on a level more than an ordinary
person and it shouldn't be that way but
we all know how the world works now this
company behind this I saw Cowboy they
didn't even report this incident until
eight hours after they'd lost it that
shows that this was probably commonplace
for them like to have mistakes to have
things go wrong oh it's all right we'll
find in they've gotten lucky probably
until now and this has explored
something that was clearly always coming
apparently they'd fired people who'd
questioned the safety measures you've
got all the doors bolted on a limited
amount of food and air the fact that
this thing isn't even able to ascend or
descend of its own accord you know even
if they were able to hit some sort of
emergency Ascent button you wouldn't
even be able to get out on the surface
anyway and the fact that it's controlled
by a remote control that is a known
faulty you know Wi-Fi not even a
PlayStation controller level control and
it's known for dying on Gamers the irony
everything about this it just blows my
[__] mind I've just found this little
video that explains depth on a basic
level here which is quite good this
gives you an idea of uh how deep these
people have gone like you see the North
Sea average there 100 meters that is
considered a deep dive in deep sea
diving you can see the Statue of Liberty
there that's how big the Statue of
Liberty is you've then got the Eiffel
Tower at 300 meters one of the biggest
buildings in the world at 829 meters and
you keep going and you keep going and
over double that and you're still not at
the Titanic step Jesus Christ what a
[__] a drop that is I mean even most
submarines don't go to the steps so
there's the Titanic now just to explain
how how deep that is but also how hard
it would be to find them it's very hard
to find this they're in Pitch Black
they've shown sunlight yeah for example
the sunlight doesn't make it down there
there is no sunlight even the average
submarine cannot get to that depth most
submarines would be crushed by the
pressure of the ocean go going anywhere
near that depth they can't and there's
only I think 10 in the world that have
been designed to go at a depth of 4 000
meters and only one of those is
uncertified by you know the the legal
committee that approves these things and
that is the one that's gone missed
coincidence I don't think so and it kind
of shows the stupidity of of people how
we're basically so excited to go and say
what is an underwater grave site that
they're willing to pay a quarter of a
million each to do it and risk their
lives and apparently the contracts that
they looked at to sign the waiver of
your life away essentially is like eight
paragraphs of you may die you may die
you know what I mean and you're like how
did someone so smart that they became a
billionaire do this and put their lives
in the faith of some little dude with a
little remote Wi-Fi controller that
doesn't even work properly of course
there's some Elite level technology in
this but far too many chances have been
taken so you're looking at the size of
the Titanic right It ultimately in the
in the ocean it's tiny yes it's massive
to humans it's tiny it's very hard to
find and only because they've charted it
and know exactly where it is can they
find it repeatedly but we're talking
about a little submersible that's 20
foot long and not attached to anything
in the power of the ocean that could be
thrown all over the place I'll be
shocked if they find it and I hope they
do for the loved one's sake but this is
a needle in the haystack and not even
it's actually that's actually better
than what we're talking about here
because at least with the haystack you
can go right when we're nowhere well
looking here I mean yeah they'll start
at the Titanic but it could be [__]
anyway I was watching an interview with
the Royal Navy commander and he was
talking about you know what level of
technology is required and he compared
it to building a car in a shed and that
really hit home for me we're talking
about the tricky Chitty Bang Bang a
[__] submersibles I know the guys who
uh pilot these ROV
um you know the the big machines with
the cameras on that you see going down
to look for these things they're very
smart guys and this type of technology
is a lead but even then you find it all
right we found it now what do we do
because they can't just get a hold of it
and take it straight up you need a whole
nother operation once you even locate it
even finding it you're not moving super
fast it's not like you're on a motorbike
sprinting around it's taking forever
hoping this wasn't going to happen
[__] out so
it's self-certifying and what you call
experimental it's self-certifying
meaning we don't have a certificate but
we're giving one to ourselves I wish
that was the way life worked because I
could just give myself a [__] degree
and look at the size of it man inside
when you think of yourself as a
billionaire a man who had everything and
to go in this kind of way where you're
in basically a tube with a bunch of
other sweaty hairy ass men breathing
your last breaths in in that way when
you had everything and you're at the
bottom of the [__] ocean all because
curiosity meant you wanted to go and see
a grave site wow a video has emerged of
the Titan launch crew and passengers
just moments before the submersible
began its descent this veteran French
explorer one of five people still
missing I've never understood this
exploration bollocks you know when
people want to climb Mount Everest or go
the deepest deaths they always think
it'll not be me I'm saying this is a
former [__] diver but equally like
it's not the same these people are
trying to break records and doom now
ever done before type [__] you're asking
for trouble like with that mindset in my
opinion we are very aware of the time
sensitivity around this mission
the equipment that's been mobilized for
this look at the mud the whole point of
this is let me go down and say the
Titanic so I can then record it on my
iPhone down there and take it back up
and show people I did but like can you
not just watch it on YouTube the US
Coast Guard reporting a second day of
underwater noises they hope are signs of
life I think these noises are a lot of
shape to be honest with you like to sit
there and act like these noises prove
anything like me start at the Titanic
and work your way out that's basic the
idea like oh no you say it like it's
like [__] I don't know I could be wrong
I hope I'm wrong I hope this noise means
something but when you think of how
thick these uh walls have to be inside
this tube that they're in the idea that
they could make banging and then that
somehow could transmit for like I don't
know
[Music]
but what I can tell you is and I think
this is the most important point we're
searching where the noises are and
that's all we can do at this point
that's why I'm worried about Paul how
about search weather was supposed to be
going and survivability could be
affected by other factors including
whether the vessel has lost power
impacting Heating and risk of
hypothermia we're listening this out but
ultimately I could have [__] employed
it these guys could be floating in the
middle of nowhere as well Ocean Gate
describes the vessel as experimental
built from carbon fiber into titanium
materials largely untested for crude
submersibles
Make It Stop they've just literally
jumped off the [__] Bridge without a
bungee and the fact that people have
survived this before it doesn't mean
that oh well that makes it fine then so
I think the weird thing about this whole
story is the way it's kind of shown how
hypocritical social media can be because
on the one hand like places like Twitter
are filled with virtue signal as just
trying to cancel people take the moral
High Ground make themselves seem like an
angel and then on the other hand a story
like this comes along where People Unite
and all of that goes out of the window
and people just seem to see the funny
side of of death and the Darkness of
[__] people it's mud I mean one guy
set up this [__] Twitter account
where he's basically tweeting out every
[__] half an hour three hours 30 left
three hours left of oxygen and he's
literally doing an image where he's
showing the ball going down to zero I
mean it's got 23 000 [__] tweets and
people like R.I.P and it's like is this
appropriate I mean I've got a dark sense
of humor so I'm any thing pretty much
goals generally but it just shows what a
load of shite this virtue signaling
world we live in is so this guy here is
a friend of one of the billionaires on
board and he said he found out they use
old scaffoldings to build it computer
game style controllers and he just said
look I'm out it's a no from me imagine
being a billionaire who's gotten
everything you wanted your entire life
now you're trapped in here as the lights
eventually flicker out and you're just
sitting in there and completing total
darkness as they realization set in that
there's no one coming for you someone
said do you think that there's a black
box I want to hear their last moments
down there so bad this is what I'm on
about virtue signaling goes out the
window when billionaires are about to
die it's all right because they're rich
because when you're seeing a strong and
powerful people are allowed to enjoy
your demise now this is [__] really
[__] weird bro so this billionaire
has got a stepson who's been wiling out
he's gone to Blink 182 since the
submersible went missing with a stepdad
on board he's now shooting a shot with
this only fans girl can I sit on you she
says he says yes please please keep my
family in your prayers may I I'm not
proud to say I have cracked onto a girl
at a funeral before right but it wasn't
my family member's funeral you know what
I'm saying this guy doesn't give a [__]
this can't be true apparently the CEO of
Ocean Gate who's actually operating the
missing vessel didn't want to hire any
experienced 50 year old white guys
because they weren't inspirational this
can't be true I need to hear this when I
started business one of the things
you'll find there are other
sub-operators out there but they they
typically
um have a gentleman who were ex-military
submariners and they you'll see a whole
bunch of 50 year old white guys
um I wanted our team to be younger to be
inspirational and I'm not going to
inspire a 16 year old to to go pursue
Marine technology but a 25 year old uh
you know who's a subpilot or a platform
operator or one of our attacks can be
inspirational I think the point is you
just want older people do you know when
I get on a plane and there's an old dude
flying the plane I want experience when
it comes to my life being in someone
else's hands you know I don't care if
you're inspirational in your the life
and soul of the party in fact if you're
really boring you probably take [__]
seriously give me a boring guy when I'm
about to put my life in their hands
boring Taxi Driver boring anything love
you shout out to the boring guys keeping
all us safe out here meanwhile yeah
these old military dudes with all their
experience can't be doing with that so
this is someone uh reading about it
actually at the place an experimental
submersible vessel that has not been
approved or certified by any regulatory
body and could result in physical injury
disability emotional trauma or death
where do I sign
oh
take your shoes off that's customary
okay
wow
inside the sub has about as much room as
a minivan so this is not your
grandfather's submersible we only have
one button that's it it should be like
an elevator you know it shouldn't take a
lot of skill the Titan is the only five
person sub in the world that can reach
Titanic depths it's also the only one
with a toilet well at least I had some
weight of [__] that's one thing
apparently The Simpsons have done it
again
foreign
[Music]
it's just oh God so that's it for True
News this week I'm gonna leave that
there obviously it's a very sad story
and as much as it's been a bit of a
light-hearted take on a dude how much
stupidity has been involved people's
lives are you know involved here and I
am hoping for a miracle but I really
don't expect one and I think that they
should be being honest about this you
can see these guys in the in doing their
bits to Media being like well we're
going to keep on looking they're
bullshitting and they're no fine well
they are so we'll keep our fingers
crossed regardless but let me know your
thoughts on this story stay subscribe to
the true Jordan YouTube channel like the
video and I'll see us on the next one